um let me ask another ridiculous
question
on this topic um how important is
touch we haven't talked much about
humans but
i have this argument with my dad
where like i think you can fall in love
with the robot
based on uh language alone and he
believes that
touch is essential i touch and smell he
says but
um so
in terms of robots you know connecting
with humans
yeah and uh we can go philosophical in
terms of like a deep meaningful
connection like
love but even just like collaborating in
an interesting way
how important is touch like
uh from engineering perspective and the
philosophical one
i think it's super important let's even
just in a practical sense if we forget
about the emotional
part of it but for robots to interact
safely while they're doing
meaningful mechanical work in the pro
in the you know close contact with or
vicinity of people that need help i
think we have to have them
they have we have to build them
differently um they have to be afraid
not afraid of touching the world so
uh i think baymax is just awesome that's
just like the the
the movie of big hero 6 and the the
concept of baymax that's just awesome i
think
we should um and we have some folks at
toyota that are trying to toyota
research that are trying to build baymax
roughly
and i think it's just a fantastically
good project
i think it will change the way people
physically interact
the same way i mean you you gave a
couple examples earlier but but if i
um if the robot that was walking around
my home
looks more like a teddy bear and a
little less like the terminator
that could change completely the way
people perceive it and interact with it
and maybe they'll even want to teach it
like you said
right you could not quite gamify it but
somehow instead of people judging it and
looking at it as
if it's not doing as well as a human
they're going to try to help out the
cute teddy bear right who knows
but i i think we're building robots
wrong
and being more soft and more contact
is important right yeah and like all the
magical moments i can remember with
robots
well first of all just visiting your lab
and seeing atlas
but also spot menu when i first spot saw
spot mini
in person and hung out with him her
it i don't have trouble engendering
robots i feel robotics people really say
always
it i kind of like the idea that it's a
her or
him uh there's a magical moment but
there's no touching uh i guess the
question i have have you ever been
like have you had a human robot
experience where
like a robot touched you
and like it was like wait like was there
a moment that you've forgotten that a
robot
is a robot and like the
anthropomorphization
stepped in and for a second you forgot
that it's not human
i mean i think when you're in on the
details
then we we of course anthropomorphized
our work with atlas but in you know
in verbal communication and the like i
think we were pretty aware
of it as a machine that needed to be
respected
um i actually i worry more about the
smaller robots that
could still you know move quickly if
programmed wrong and uh
and we have to be careful actually about
safety and the like right now
and that if we build our robots
correctly i think then
those a lot of those concerns could go
away and we're seeing that trend we're
seeing the lower cost lighter weight
arms now that could be fundamentally
safe
um i mean i do think touch is so
fundamental
ted adelson is uh is great he's a
perceptual scientist
at mit uh and he
studied vision most of his life and he
said uh when i had
kids i expected to be fascinated by
their perceptual development
but what really what he noticed was felt
more impressive more dominant was the
way that they would touch everything and
lick everything and pick things up stick
it on their tongue and whatever
and he said watching his daughter uh
convinced him that actually he needed to
study tactile sensing more
so there's something very um
important i think it's it's a little bit
also of the passive versus active
part of the world right you can
passively perceive the world
but it's fundamentally different if you
can do an experiment right
and if you can change the world and you
can learn a lot more
than a passive observer so
you can in dialogue that was your
initial example you could have an
active experiment exchange but i think
if you're just a camera watching youtube
i think that's a very different problem
than if you're a
robot that can apply force and touch
i i i think it's important
yeah i think it's just an exciting area
of research i think you're probably
right that this hasn't been
under researched it's uh
to me as a person who's captivated by
the idea of human robot interaction
it feels like such a rich opportunity
to explore touch not even from a safety
perspective but like you said the
emotional
too i mean safety comes first
but the next step is like
you know like a real human connection
even in the war like even in the
industrial setting it just feels like uh
it's nice for the robot i don't know i
you know you might disagree with this
but um
because i think it's important to see
robots as tools
often but i don't know i think they're
just always going to be more effective
once
you humanize them uh like
it's convenient now to think of them as
tools because we want to focus on the
safety
but i think ultimately to create
like a good experience for the worker
for
the person there has to be a human
element i don't know for me i i
it feels like like an industrial robotic
arm
would be better if as a human element i
think like we think robotics had that
idea with
baxter and having eyes and so on having
i don't know i'm a big believer in that
i it's not my area
but i am also a big believer do you have
an emotional connection to atlas
like yeah do you miss him i mean um
yes i i i don't know if i'd more so than
if i had a
different science project that i'd
worked on super hard right but
uh um
yeah i mean the the robot we basically
had to do heart surgery on the robot in
the final competition because we melted
the core
um and uh and
yeah there was something about watching
that robot hanging there we know we had
to compete with it in an hour and it was
getting its guts ripped out those are
all historic moments
i think if you look back like 100 years
from now
um yeah i think those are important
moments in robotics
i mean these are the early day you look
at like the early days of a lot of
scientific disciplines they look
ridiculous they're full of failure
but it feels like robotics will be
important
in the coming hundred years and these
are the early days
so
you